a friendship that kick-started an
actor's entire film career an on-screen
politician with the approval of a real
president here's what the cast of
District 9 have been up to since the
film's 2009 release
Charles Copley made his feature-length
acting debut as District 9's protagonist
vikas van damerva working at
multinational United or mnu the military
contractor assigned to keeping the
prawns in check vikas is tasked with
relocating the 1.8 million aliens to
another Camp when he is exposed to alien
fluid that slowly transforms him into a
prawn Eminem is trying to move the
aliens for humanitarian reasons but the
real Focus just as it has been right
from the beginning is weapons when mnu
tries to dissect vicus so that they can
use his alien DNA to access alien
technology he escapes and becomes a
fugitive of the law with nowhere else to
go vikas makes a deal to help a Quran
named Christopher Johnson and his son
little CJ leave Earth in order to save
himself District 9 was actually copley's
feature-length debut he was close
friends with director Neil blomkamp who
offered him the role the performance
marked the beginning of a busy career
for Copley since 2009 he starred in
several other movies such as 2010's the
A-Team 2013's old boy and 2014's
Maleficent he was also the lead on the
PlayStation Network TV series Powers
which premiered in 2015 and lasted for
two seasons Copley continued to work
with blomkamp on feature films like
2013's Elysium and 2015's chappie and
short films including 2017's God
Serengeti and 2018's God City from Oates
Studios Jason cope may not be a
household name but the South African
actor did play a major role in District
9. for starters Coke did the motion
capture work for Christopher Johnson and
all the speaking aliens cope also played
the Human UK NR correspondent gray
bradnam who has interviewed several
times throughout the film cope continued
to score roles in other projects he
appeared in several films over the years
such as 2012's dread in 2013's Mandela
long walk to freedom and had a recurring
role on the Stars TV series Black Sails
cope also continued to collaborate with
blomkamp as he appeared in 2015's
chappie and three of the director's
short films with oat Studios God
Serengeti God City and 2017's Adam the
mirror
David James is another relatively
unknown South African actor who played a
major role in District 9. James
portrayed one of the film's main
antagonists kubis Venter a ruthless and
sadistic mnu mercenary who accompanies
vicus during the eviction of District 9
before attempting to capture him after
he is infected as seen throughout the
film kubis takes great pleasure in
torturing and murdering prawns
since the film makes kubis so easy to
hate it's fairly cathartic to see the
prawns defeat kubis at the end of the
movie while some other critics deemed
James District 9 performance as
deserving of an Oscar he mostly played
minor roles after its release James
appeared in several British TV shows
such as Wild at Heart and kidnap and
Ransom
South African actress and model Vanessa
Haywood played vickis's wife Tanya in
District 9. at the beginning of the film
it becomes very clear that Tanya loves
vicus dearly and is concerned for him
when he is taken to the hospital after
vikas becomes a fugitive however mnu
spreads lies that he had sexual
relations with an alien which leads
Tanya to turn on him I'm gonna fix my um
and I'm gonna I'm gonna see you again
and I'm gonna kiss you and I'm gonna
hold you again
near the end of the film it begins to
seem that Tanya's feelings about her
husband have changed again she seems
forlorn without vicus and keeps a metal
flower that she believes he made this
theory is seemingly confirmed by the
last shot of the film which features a
prawn presumably vicus now fully
transformed crafting another metal
flower although Haywood hasn't acted in
many projects since then she has still
been heavily involved in the worldwide
entertainment industry in 2011 Haywood
competed in the Survivor South Africa
episode celebs vs klebs which she says
was a phenomenal life-changing
experience for her Haywood is also a
respected endurance athlete who is not
only married to South African Trail
Runner Ryan Sands but has also competed
in several races such as the Absa Cape
epic the Leadville 100 and the otter
Trail race
South African actor Mandela goduga
played fundiswa malonga in District 9.
fandiswa is vikas's assistant and
trainee during the eviction in the end
fondishwa awaits trial for exposing
information about mnu's illegal
experimentation on prawns although
gaduca's role in District 9 was small it
had a major impact on the film's climax
since the release of District 9 gduka
found plenty of success in South African
television he won two South African film
and television Awards or saftas for his
work on the comedy hautang mabonang and
another one for his work on the soap
opera ashes to ashes gduka continued to
pop up in several movies after District
9. he appeared in 2011's machine gun
preacher in 2015 he portrayed an unnamed
Johannesburg resident in Avengers Age of
Ultron more recently he appeared in
2019's losing Lorado
malawian actor Eugene cambanya played
obesanjo the secondary antagonist of
District 9. this ominous looking
character is in charge of the Nigerian
gang in District 9 which sells aliens
cat food in exchange for their weapons
obasanjo believes that he can use alien
Weaponry if he eats alien flesh during
the film's climax one of obasanjo's men
tries to cut off vikas's mutated arm
when little CJ remotely activates an
exoskeleton inside the Nigerian gang's
compound which kills all the gangsters
and blows up obasanjo's head after
District 9 cabanua starred in many
television projects from around the
world he played Pastor Peter in the 2016
British TV movie demilola our loved boy
the film which also starred Lovecraft
country actress won me masako won two
British Academy of film and television
Awards kombanyua also appeared in the
critically acclaimed Hulu miniseries the
looming Tower as Trenton okuku a Kenyan
security guard at the American Embassy
in Nairobi who survived the embassy
bombing and became a crucial witness
additionally kombanyua continued to work
with blumkamp after District 9 playing
another gangster in the 2015 feature
chappie he also appeared in blomkamp's
2017 short film raqqa which alongside
chappie starred Sigourney Weaver
Kenneth nicosi played Thomas a good
friend of vikas in District 9. Thomas is
an mnu security guard who assists vikas
in the alien eviction serving as vikas
personal security detail although nikosi
played a minor role in District 9 he was
already a name in South African film and
likely appeared in the movie to attract
South African moviegoers fortunately
nikosi continued to pop up in movies TV
shows and live broadcasts some examples
of the former include 2011's scheme and
2015's ayanda both of which have either
been nominated for or won saftas more
recently he also starred in the 2018
family Comedy Frank and fearless he also
hosted the sabc2 World Cup in 2010 as
well as several South African reality
shows such as Class Act Wang berstana
and kitchen Queens
Louis Minar played Pyatt Smith one of
the main antagonists in District 9.
Hyatt is the managing director of mnu
who sends his bumbling son-in-law
Vickers to evict aliens from District 9.
while he couldn't have predicted what
was going to happen to vikas he was
probably hoping for the worst I had to
put aside the fact that my daughter was
married to Vegas
that didn't factor in my decision to
promote her after vikas is infected
Pyatt decides to vivisect him for
research and stares emotionlessly at his
son-in-law as he begs for his life after
vikas becomes a fugitive Pyatt lies to
his daughter Tanya that vikas had sexual
relations with a Brawn to turn her
against him although his status at the
end of the movie is unknown Hyatt was
likely implicated in the data leak of
mnu's illegal alien experimentation
which he was a large part of after
District 9 Minar popped up in more
movies from around the world some of his
South African filmography includes
2012's semi-sweet 2017's Veil vas Hood
and 2019's the Harvesters Minar also
appeared in Clint Eastwood's 2009 Nelson
Mandela biopic Invictus
American actor William Allen Young
played Dirk Michaels the CEO of mnu in
District 9. although young is one of the
more established actors in the film's
cast his character only appears in two
scenes an interview where he says that
the aliens are not going anywhere and a
newscast where he says the explosion at
the mnu headquarters is a terrorist
attack well there was a terrorist attack
but I can assure you that we've dealt
with it everything is fine after
District 9 young made guest appearances
on dozens of TV shows as well as acting
in some movies Castle Madam Secretary
and this is us are just a few of the
shows that young popped up in the only
movies that young has acted in since
District 9 are TV movies like 2011's
rocked the house 24 teams the cookie
mobster and 2019's Christmas Hotel young
is also a well-respected humanitarian he
has received several distinguished
Awards including the NAACP Achievement
Award the president's icon award and the
Man of the Year award from the National
Organization of Women at work
additionally President Bill Clinton
named young an ambassador of Goodwill
which means that he advocates for a
specific cause or Global issue on the
basis of his notability as a public
figure
South African actor Robert Hobbs played
a minor character in District 9 named
Pinar an mnu mercenary under the command
of kubis Venter he is seen in the
firefight with Nigerians near the end of
the film and is ordered to beat up
Christopher to make him talk about his
plans with vikas after Pinar is ordered
to execute Christopher the audience sees
the slightest trace of a smile on his
face he almost pulls the trigger before
vikas uses the exosuit's gun to
dismember him since District 9 Hobbes
has appeared in several movies and TV
shows such as Mandela long walk to
Freedom Black Sails and Warrior Hobbes
also continued to collaborate with
blomkamp acting in chappie in 2015 and
two of his short films raqqa and
Firebase in 2017.
[Music]
foreign